[Music]
foreign
view a first look at what is on the
front pages time then to see what's
making the headlines with the
broadcaster and political commentator
Salma Shaw and the senior political
correspondent at the new Statesman Harry
Lambert who are both at the Conservative
Party Conference in Birmingham so let us
take a look then at the front pages
well the eye uh Tori open warfare that's
how the eye describes the situation at
the body conference after days of
infighting over tax cut u-turns and
fears for benefit payments leave Liz
trust struggling after just 29 days in
charge the Metro Pictures the PM looking
a little bit like Bob the Builder and
asking appropriately perhaps can she fix
it
the telegraph looks ahead to her keynote
conference speech tomorrow with a
warning that things will get worse
before they get better but it will be
worth it in the end
the express also adopts the building
theme ahead of the speech in Birmingham
the times two leads with Liz truss's
expected comments tomorrow
the financial times meanwhile says she's
trying to Rally skeptical members of her
own party behind her but the guardian
leads with claims of a possible coup
already being planned to unseat her from
the leadership
the start says the chancellor has found
something new to blame for the tax
U-turn shambles the Queen's funeral
while the Daily Mail claims an exclusive
with an apparent pledge by the police
that an officer will be sent to every
reported burglary in future
quick reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out the front pages
optimize newspapers Wally watches so
let's head straight to our guests then
uh broadcaster political commentator
Salma Shaw senior political
correspondent at the new Statesman Harry
Lambert welcome to both of you we will
come on to Liz truss's speech uh in a
moment but first of all let's reflect on
today or in fact the last few days with
the eye Salma Tory open Warfare has she
lost control and has she lost
credibility and Authority
I think it's pretty hard uh to say that
she hasn't lost control and this is
probably one of the most ill-disciplined
conservative party conferences that I
think certainly I've attended in a very
very long time
um the ifront page details uh you know
all the various things that are going
wrong and you know how other MPS are
sort of trying to Galvanize against her
but there's one that particularly sticks
out on that front page and it's Nadine
Dory is making an intervention about the
fact that she shouldn't move too much
away from the 2019 Manifesto
um and that if she did it would require
a general election so I think what's
interesting about this is that it's not
just the Michael goves of the world that
didn't support her but actually people
that were really strongly supportive of
Liz truss's leadership that are now sort
of criticizing and warning her against
moving away from what she pledged in the
leadership campaign yes Nadine Doris uh
speaking tonight I think we'll look back
on this in the future we removed the
Prime Minister who won us the biggest
majority since 1979 in less than three
years of winning that majority
conservative MPS in the future may have
a lot to answer for
um certainly if you look at the polls
right now um You Might agree with her in
fact but the I as well Harry
um suggesting that trust's position is
not safe a minister tells the eye we've
been here before we might have to do it
again I mean she's got a lot not to do
hasn't she in that big speech to
conference on Wednesday
she has but it may already be too late I
think the remarkable thing that we've
seen over the last 10 days really is
that the political dial has shifted this
is the moment a little bit like
September 2007 when Gordon brownfeld to
call an election and The credibility of
the labor party was shot or even
September 92 with black Wednesday when
the Tory party's credibility was shocked
you know walking around conference the
last few days you just feel like the
temperature has changed and that the
conservative party itself is losing its
credibility it's not just about the
latest leader it's about the party as a
whole and you see that in the polling
data down 25 points now in the headline
polls and and for the first time as I
say since 2007 they've lost the record
that that their record of competence on
the economy yes and certainly some
people suggesting it's now existential
for the Tories with polling like that
it's almost Wipeout time uh the eye
again suggesting that she's been told
she has 10 days to save her Premiership
so we move on uh somewhere to the Daily
Telegraph uh disruption is the price of
success is what she will say tomorrow
Liz truss will warn that there will be
further disruption as she fights to
deliver economic growth
um but insisting that she would reshape
the country and there can be no more
drift and and delay in the effort to
boost economic growth and defending her
new approach which will she says unleash
the full potential of our great country
the problem is whether she has time to
wait for that Salma
yes and I think it's interesting because
of course the telegraph is sort of a
traditionally right-wing paper and we'll
obviously try and give her the benefit
of the doubt before this speech but this
speech strangely even though she's only
been prime minister for a month
um and it should have been an amazing
celebratory event for her this
conference is ending up being a make or
break moment for her and as you've
rightly pointed out in sort of the the
extracts that you've taken from her
speech or the words that are expected
she's actually really doubling down on
her vision for growth and what's
interesting about that is that it could
have been an opportunity for her to try
and broaden the tent try and bring some
of these people in try and show a bit of
Contrition but she's already had a huge
U-turn this week on the 45p rate of tax
and she seems to want to try and regain
the control by again like as I say
doubling down and I'm not entirely sure
that that is going to be successful
tomorrow you have Daily Express PM my
changes will disrupt but build a better
future more words from this trust in
fact they've released you know more than
normal I would suggest possibly for too
long our economy has not grown as
strongly as it should have done for too
long the political debate has been
dominated by how we distribute a limited
economic pie instead we need to grow the
pie so that everyone gets a bigger slice
that is why I am determined to take a
new approach and break us out of the of
this High tax low growth cycle that is
what our plan is about getting our
economy growing and rebuilding Britain
through reform
um the low growth suggestion I mean some
might say in the country not in her
party that that was partly austerity
brought in by the conservatives in 2010
and also possibly by brexit so you know
could you argue the last 12 years has
effectively slowed growth because of
what the conservative party have done
Harry
foreign
I think absolutely I think you you
captured two of the the key issues and
there's a third one which is the NHS
backlog uh quasi-quarten's team that his
spokesman after his uh catastrophic
budget statement conceded to the lobby
at the time that if they were just able
to get back into work many of the people
had been forced uh off six since covid
growth would really increase by maybe as
much as a percentage point and a big
reason why people haven't come back from
being long-term sick after covert is
because of the NHS backlog and the
government's inability to give the NHS
the money it needs and that's only going
to be more likely now they're cutting
taxes for the top rates of income of
course they've reduced to 45p rate but
on the whole we're still seeing unfunded
tax cuts and I think you know there's
always been an irony to the brexit
project which is the office for Budget
responsibility he was saying it's a four
percent cut in long-term economic growth
and that was something that was seen as
a price they were willing to pay and yet
now we hear nothing but the of the need
for economic growth so that's attention
at the heart of the conference all week
now yep the time also going with it
brace for more change says trust the
disrupter uh the financial times as well
trust strives to Rally MPS after tourism
renew their infighting over benefits
threat
um it's just 30 minutes we're told this
speech will be to to try to bring Unity
uh to her party
um does she need to have a cabinet
reshuffle in order to bring those who
might criticize her into the fold does
she need to stop being the disrupter
what might help her at this stage summer
um so just to say I think for a lot of
people limiting the speech to 30 minutes
is probably quite a welcome thing uh
especially a nice departure I would say
from the 50 to 60 Minutes that you used
to have to listen to a leader go on
um but there is a lot that she could do
whether it's enough to sort of stabilize
and whether she's willing to do it I
think is an important question so you
mentioned reshuffle yes she could bring
some of her critics back into the fold
but then that will create a lot of
tension and a lot of conflict within the
cabinet and I'm not sure she would
actually be able to get through what she
really truly believes in I think I mean
I don't know what you think about this
Harry but like she really does believe
the stuff that she's talking about so
there isn't really that sense of kind of
balance or consensus that I think she's
looking for I think she in some senses
quite likes that conflict and she feels
like she's trying to usher in this new
economic age and this new period of
growth but isn't the whole problem that
there's never been a basis for our
belief system or at least she hasn't
outlined one to the country you saw
there was polling data this week showing
that
the word that people now associate with
trust above all others is incompetence
and we might be more inclined to trust
her if we had a good reason to believe
that her plans were going to lead to
growth what are the reasons to believe
in this
well I'm sure this is what I'm hoping
that she's going to set out tomorrow but
I think one of the things that has been
really interesting in this conference is
that a lot of it has been based on
rhetoric and not hugely substantive and
I'm sure we'll be going through the
papers uh you know a few other papers to
see what the actual meat of the policy
is and I think the meat of the policy
has been quite light this conference yes
I mean you know you can you can kind of
see why can't you
um the u-turn on the highest rate of
attacks Harry politically expedient but
certainly for leadership reasons
weakening is it not and it's led to a
bravman today it's in the Telegraph and
in fact the guardian talking about
there'd been a coup now if you want to
try and bring Unity criticizing your
colleagues for staging a coup is perhaps
not the best way of doing it foreign
Collective responsibility uh it's an
extraordinary situation you have Simon
Clark as the papers touch on essentially
quote tweeting swella bravaman and Anna
green with her view
um you've also got you know the likes of
penny more than openly coming out and
saying we need to to a pining on on
benefit policy so I think you know we've
now reached a point
today as well Lord Frost 2 coming out
suggesting that you know benefits need
to stick to an inflation rise not a
wages rise but anyway do continue sorry
it just it feels like the final days of
the May era you know when you just had
everyone signing off and we're in week
four of the trust Premiership so it's
really a remarkable situation in that
sense
well give us a sense of the um the mood
there I heard one person say it was 50
times worse than when Ian Duncan Smith
was in charge of the party and he was
out two months later what what is your
analysis and assessment of uh what it's
been like
um so I don't remember the Ian Duncan's
fifth days so I can only take it as uh
as read that uh that's that's how it
felt but um surprisingly and I think
lots of people will disagree and I'm
sure Harry Will
um that the mood here has been strangely
quite buoyant and I don't know if that
is because there's a lot of people who
are sort of true trust believers who
were in attendance at this conference
um or whether it's because people are
sort of have decided that you know this
is one of the last hurrays that we're
going to have but certainly there's been
you know a lot of energy and a lot of
activity and that might also be driven
in part by the fact that it has been so
chaotic um but I think this is the point
is that the Prime Minister when they
come to conference they're not just
talking to whoever's in the hall they're
actually talking to the country because
the whole nation reports on it watches
it uh is intrigued to see what's going
to happen and what announcements are
coming
um so I think that is that's the kind of
conflict that we're seeing
um between what the membership and the
activist is sort of looking at and
thinking and feeling and what people at
home who aren't attached to the
conservative party and aren't
necessarily interested in the sort of
internal machinations of what happened
and what they're actually expecting and
looking for yes and in fact it did I I
did reflect oh God I'm sorry I was just
going to say I did reflect this week
that the fact that during her hostings
Liz truss did direct what she said to
the members and not to the country
whether she's kind of reaping the
rewards for that now just very quickly
well exactly she was elected by the
members about 80 000 of them they were
never representative of the public and
therefore a conference like this is
always going to be a bad temperature
test for how well she's doing but it it
pales in comparison to the mood at Labor
conference last week let's put it that
way yeah I think we've I think we've
gleaned that if I want to stay there
there we are lots of us still to come
including we'll look at this story on
the front page of the Daily Mail the
headline Official Police to attend every
burglary that and more after this
foreign
[Music]
watching The Press preview with me once
again the broadcaster and political
commentator Salma Shaw and the senior
political correspondent at the new
Statesman Harriet Lambert welcome to
both of you
um Ukraine uh Harry making the front
pages uh once again first of all what
seemed to be rapid advances by Ukrainian
forces in both the East and in fact now
the south of the country confirmed by
the Ukrainian president but also a spat
with Elon Musk so if you'd like to just
wrap those together that would be
brilliant
small subjects
in
the
world
sure so Elon Musk has has taken to
giving
um not even advice so much as a command
as to how the war in Ukraine and Russia
should seemingly end uh suggesting that
Crimea should be left for the Russians
he said it's been Russian since 1783 and
some people pointed out that much of the
United States wasn't part of the United
States uh in 1783.
um but he He suggests that the uh the
ukrainians are sort of holding up peace
in some manner zelenski then came back
and put out a poll saying did you prefer
the musk that supports Ukraine or the
one that supports Russia it's all a bit
of a sideshow from the real story here
which is that Ukraine has as we know
over the last couple of months
finally and really the last few weeks
and even days finally pushed both in the
East and in the south in her song where
the Russians are encircled
um there are about 20 000 troops there
the Ukraine's the ukrainians using the
uh the himas weapons supplied by the
Americans have damaged the two bridges
that allow the Russians
um to resupply those troops and
therefore it's really just a matter of
time and we've been waiting for the
Breakthrough and that increasingly seems
to be happening there and having already
happened in the East and so now the
excitement of military circles is is
where does the Ukraine deploy its
strategic Reserve in other words it's
its third mass of troops and people are
hoping that they might try and cut two
fronts in half and Advance on Melita
pole so you know musk is a sideshow here
on the ground things uh things are
looking good for the ukrainians yes and
we saw pictures there of Lehman which
has been liberated for the ukrainians in
the East and that uh makes you realize
where the Guardians headline reads what
was it all for shattered limit picks up
the pieces because that was indeed
shattered was it not now we get to the
Daily Mail I thought you wanted to talk
about burglary but maybe you want to
talk about regular Christie so Selma
maybe you want to talk about both of
them for me a little bit like Harry had
to
well the the mail is covering crime and
Justice altogether on its front page and
first and foremost the splash is about a
commitment of police Chiefs up and down
the country for police officers to
attend every incident of burglary
um in their patches now as a former home
home office special advisor I have to
say that I am slightly skeptical at that
undertaking and whether it can be
fulfilled there are still uh you know
lots of things to do in order to meet
the manifesto commitment to recruit to
20 000 more police officers that I think
would be helpful to that but I also
think that uh you know as soon as it
doesn't happen it's going to become a
big story so um reserving judgment for
how well that's how well that's going to
pan out and then moving on to the
Justice part of the mail Splash
um uh in in the wag of the Christie
trial obviously Colleen Rooney came out
on top and uh it's now being reported
that damages have been awarded to her
from Rebecca bardi to the tune of 1.5
million pounds so I think another
another interesting chapter in this uh
soap opera Saga
which which the newspapers have followed
with great interest one might say uh
Salma Salma Shah and Harry Lambert
lovely to see you both thank you very
much indeed thank you